[Music]
my dad never knew his father
in 1957 when he was 31 years old he died
in a freak accident
my dad was just three at the time and so
he grew up never knowing the man who
helped bring him into the world the only
piece of him that he has and as far as i
know the only piece he's ever seen
is an air force portrait that he keeps
on his dresser you may remember my dad
from a video last year where i made a
recreation of a hot sauce that he used
to sell that was stolen from him and
while i was digging through old photos
and documents to do some research in
order to make that video
i came across something a box of eight
millimeter film
labeled beverly children beverly was my
dad's name at birth but it was also his
father's name
and upon close inspection of one of the
reels a man can be seen who looks
remarkably like my father
he's holding a child presumably either
my dad or his brother
and i'm almost certain my dad has never
seen this footage
so today i want to try and give him a
look at his father for the first time in
his life
thankfully the film is already developed
it would be nearly impossible to develop
70 year old film especially stuff that
hasn't been well stored like
this hasn't been but aside from looking
at the frames one by one i don't really
have a great way to view what's on these
reels
so i'm taking them to a local processor
to see if i can get them digitized one
of the reels is in a bit better
condition than the other but i'm hopeful
we can get something out of both
they said the footage is going to take
about a week to process so in the
meantime i want to learn a little bit
more about my grandfather
or at least whatever my dad can tell me
he was in the air force he was
a member of the jolly rogers unit
he was a gunner pilot flew 22 missions
in the korean war
i didn't see him obviously a lot slim
slim memories
of him not hardly nothing he's like a
fog
i remember our house distinctly we all
lived in but i didn't see him much
probably because
he was in the korean war when he got out
of the air force he got tons of job
offers in memphis
and he refused all jobs he wanted to go
to florida after the war he just wanted
to be a bartender in florida for a year
or two until he
settled down you can imagine that after
being in a war you want to kind of do
something relaxing yeah
especially being a gunner pilot in 22
missions knowing where you were doing
with your bullets
the jolly rogers made a book and it had
the whole crew in the book it was a
picture book my father dede
threw it away only pictures of him i had
that's the memories i have only going oh
my god
this is him this is what he did and what
what a tragedy i'd have that book
forever
when he drowned i remember standing
outside of a motel at night and
i'd never forget the fluorescent lights
of the old 1950s motel of my head my
grandmother standing there
i must have known that they were looking
for my father and i remember
finding out about his death when i was
back home in memphis
i was sitting in the living room floor
four years old and
the maid was there and she was ironing
and all of a sudden the front door
swings open
and this neighborhood boy runs in and
goes your daddy's dead your daddy's dead
your daddy's dead
and that's how i found out the maid
grabbed him and threw him
out the front door that's a distinct
memory
not many people drown water skiing but
i'm sure that he wasn't wearing a light
preserver and i'm sure they'd been
all drinking and i'm sure she was
driving was wasted
because he that's him he was that a
party boy
and my mom was there with betty jo her
best friend with bob we were only in
memphis for probably another
year or two at the most we moved to
atlanta
so yeah i don't have a lot of memories i
wish i did it's it's
unfortunate i never got to know him
oh my goodness he looks so much like my
dad
i couldn't have hoped for anything
better than this so now i have to drive
to vermont to show it to him
i know this drive is going to be filled
with nervous anticipation because i
truly don't know how he's going to react
to this
i just really hope it makes him happy
ready yeah
there you go oh my god
oh my god that's my father how did you
have this made
god man
first live video i've ever seen with him
now he's walking down this is vero beach
he says come on this is the year before
he died
and he's in the water or he drowned he's
got a cigarette he's almost burning me
with it
we're opening up presents it looks like
i'm trying to decide if he looks like my
brother or me
camera hog that must be my brother no oh
there's my mother what a great picture
of my mother
she was so lovely i can't believe he
died a year from this
this happy man life would have been so
different
seen him
amazing i've never been wow
pretty well choked up right now
hmm this is where we went every year
even after he died we went until i was
probably 15
16. oh my god
this is so great having this i mean i
just i can't believe i'm this age and
now i'm just
looking at my father the first time i
said well thank you dakota
that's the nicest thing in the world
and now i'm just like oh my god i can't
believe it all i have
i only think has that one picture of him
upstairs i'm amazed
look at my father and my mother at that
age they were a nice looking couple boy
these
pictures dakota it's like he's real i
mean he's alive and he's real and
knowing that that's
how far away from his death it's less
than a year
and now i have a vivid picture of my
father right now saying it's right in
front of me i can see him i'll see him
forever now
[Music]
oh
[Music]